palantir has bought gold
can't make it up palantir uh has spent
50 million dollars on 100 ounce gold
bars in preparation for a black swan
event concierge data analytics software
maker founded by peter thiel stephen
cohen alex carp and others in 2003
business almost 20 years old and they
are looking forward or maybe not looking
forward to but preparing for some sort
of unpredictable or random event they
are keeping the gold in a secure
location in the northeast of the united
states and customers can now pay for
their software in gold or bitcoin so
either one gold or bitcoin they will go
ahead and do uh and people were already
able to buy their software and bitcoin
but gold was recently added so palantir
is
pretty
interesting decision that in q1 at the
end of q1 they said they were
considering investing in bitcoin
it is unclear i don't think we have any
confirmation they've actually bought
bitcoin but it is clear that they spent
50 million dollars on gold bars 100
ounce gold bars and so when you start to
think about a business that is debt-free
revenue has drastically accelerated this
year they have about 2.3 billion dollars
in cash
they've added 20 new customers this year
100 new sales people and in q2 they did
376 million dollars in top line revenue
which was about 50 growth year over year
it is absolutely nuts
to think about them going and buying
gold like what what is the logic for
buying gold over bitcoin right now given
that gold is down 10
year over year and also it's down three
percent over the last decade or so well
it sounds like they they like sound
money but i don't know if they figured
out uh the newer version of that which
is bitcoin right and i think uh they're
paying storage fees they're doing all
these things they're accepting bitcoin
maybe they hold some of it or whatever
if people end up paying with it but i
think we've seen like when it comes to
tesla and some of these other businesses
that are accepting bitcoin for payment
like no one's paying in bitcoin and it's
not because it's not necessarily a good
uh medium of exchange it's because they
believe the price is going to appreciate
right and you're not going to trade
something in that's going to appreciate
in value a month a year 10 years from
now right so
gold has traditionally served as that
application of sound money they think
they see inflation being super high they
see the government printing a bunch of
money they see unemployment high they
see people struggling in this country
and they see and they estimate that
something is going to happen they call
it a black swan event so i think that uh
they're telling us that they want sound
money they're uh applying it on the
older version of it they accept the
newer version of it maybe they're uh
keeping some of it instead of selling it
back into the market or transferring it
back to whatever currency they want but
over time i would assume that they'll go
back and reanalyze that decision and
realize kind of the differences between
gold and bitcoin is this the new model
not to keep cash
i mean think about it if inflation's so
high if a black swan event comes right
you want to be able to like have an
alternative asset or store value that
isn't going to get uh devalued over time
and it seems like more and more
companies have done this now they're
doing it with gold but so they they
obviously need some sort of uh
customers want to pay in cash so they
need to be able to accept cash they need
some amount of it to do their regular
commerce and their activities and pay
employees and do all those type of
things so there's obviously a need to
keep a certain level of cash on your
balance sheet regardless of what you're
doing
but i think at the end of the day it
just comes down to what they believe is
going to happen in the market if they
believe that there's going to be a crash
where the market devalues over time then
they're going to go and uh they're going
to opt in for sound money or an
application of that whether it's the
digital or the analog version and say uh
this is what we want to keep we have a
quote from the chief operating officer
at palantir that says accepting
non-traditional currencies
reflects more of a world view you have
to be prepared for a future with more
black swan events and so i think this is
it right it's just look there's lots of
uncertainty in the world today and
frankly the uncertainty is both the
events that happen
and the response to events right so
nobody can predict a pandemic was
occurring it happens people obviously uh
are going to do what they're going to do
but then on top of that you also get the
responses and the response was different
in different countries it's also
different in different states we see a
place like new zealand i think it just
came out they have one case an immediate
lockdown right and so is that going to
be the new norm nobody knows it's
uncertainty of the future and so when
you live in that world what do you want
well you probably actually want some
diversification so you've got dollars
they've got now gold and it appears to
be that they've got some bitcoin given
that people could uh could be paying
them in bitcoin for this software and so
i do think it brings back the question
of if they're going after sound money
right which is basically it's outside
the system and no one can create more of
it both gold or bitcoin gold is the
analog application bitcoin is the
digital application of that right and so
if we go to uh the analog application
you you kind of ran over it but you
mentioned it is that they have to pay
custody cost somewhere and it's not in
their actual physical control there is
third party risk of let's say that i own
physical gold and i give it to joe
maybe i get it back maybe i don't if i
give it to john john's definitely giving
it back joe i'm not so sure right with
bitcoin i have the sovereignty myself
second is that's like from a security
standpoint second then becomes what is
the
ability to
uh preserve purchasing power so there's
like a risk management component gold
happens to have for five thousand years
done a very good job of it in the last
15 months not so hot also in the last 10
years not so hot bitcoin has done a much
better job it's younger though right
it's newer to the market and so they it
sounds like they're trying to hedge and
get exposure to both but in either case
only 50 million dollars of gold bought
of 2.3 billion dollars in cash if this
was bitcoin they were announcing
bitcoins would be going nuts but the
same critique would be true whether it's
gold or bitcoin it's just not that much
right they got 2.3 billion in cash you
only buy 50 million dollars of it it
almost feels like it's kind of a
throwaway hedge and
sure maybe it means something kind of uh
from a an ethos or a perspective
standpoint but it's not really going to
do anything to protect their balance
sheet right pelina uh yes
no um do you do you think that palantir
watched our segment with peter schiff
and decided to buy gold i think that
palantir and peter schiff are on
completely different ends of the
spectrum in terms of uh technical and uh
software proficiency and then there's
peter schiff with dial-up internet so
so in may
they asked the cfo of palantir and they
asked could you ever see palantir having
bitcoin or any other type of
cryptocurrency on its balance sheet and
they he said the short answer is yes
we're thinking about it and we've even
discussed it internally take a look at
our balance sheet 2.3 billion in cash
like you said
including 151 million in adjusted free
cash flow in q1 so it's definitely on
the table from a treasury perspective as
well as other investments as we look
across our business and beyond so do we
think that they maybe also put bitcoin
on their balance sheet but we just don't
have to announce it yeah they would
announce it so here's what i think this
business has an advantage this is very
similar to like a micro strategy may
even be in a better position so let's
look at the volunteer business itself
they got 62 deals worth a million
dollars or more they've got 30 deals
that are worth 5 million or more 21
deals that are worth 10 million or more
and when you start to look at this
growth this is just their government
quarterly revenue through uh q2 of 2021
absolute insane growth right you're
literally talking about from q1 2020
where they had about 118 million dollars
uh to 232 million by this last quarter
just taking off but they also had that
free cash flow i think it was nine
digits of free cash flow on a quarterly
basis so when you have the free cash
flow what you basically can do is you
have optionality you can decide what do
i do with this cash flow do i go ahead
and i just put it in cash do i put it
into some sort of uh bond and treasury
strategy do i put it into gold do i put
it into bitcoin do i invest it from an r
d perspective do i go hire more people
like when you have cash flow you get to
make decisions because you're playing
offense if this business was losing
money on a quarterly basis you would
start to really question okay now you're
playing more defense and they actually
may make different decisions given where
uh they have these long-term software
contracts they're not profitable but
they don't have any debt which they have
no debt but it's just free but didn't
they just say that they have free cash
flow
yeah
but but they may be there's accounting
tricks let's just let's just say there's
tons of accounting tricks that can be
getting played in terms of what they're
showing from cash flow versus ebitda
versus uh gap non-get there's all kinds
of tricks that can get played uh with
these things with john see if you can
find more about yeah their net income uh
of december 2020 was a minus 140 million
bucks yeah see okay so here here we
start playing games with uh various
sources telling us various things so
we'll have to look later to see exactly
what the business is but you said john
that december 2020 net income was
negative what
138 million okay so that was for
december 2020 and then plenty the number
you saw with that q1 was the q1 number
yeah it says well the cfo said including
151 million in adjusted free cash flow
in q1 yeah just in the keyword there
yeah all right we'll dig into that later
i'm not gonna i'm not going to do the
public math and figure out how they're
defining adjusted uh in terms of their
commercial revenue it grew 28
year-over-year in q2 uh and their u.s
commercial revenue growth accelerated by
90 year-over-year so some of this may be
contributing to to the end of 2020
versus like a q2 number where they're
just seeing a massive increase in the
actual revenue of the business and then
we've got uh kind of two more uh charts
here where we've got uh q2 they had 3.4
billion dollars in total remaining deal
value up 63 year over year and then they
also have 20 net new customers in q2
2021. remember if people are paying
millions of dollars and you get 20 new
customers uh in a single quarter
business is boom so do we know they said
that they're going to accept uh bitcoin
as a payment going forward along with
gold and some other uh currencies and
stuff do we know if they're going to
keep the bitcoin on their balance sheet
if they do if someone pays in bitcoin i
think that it's going to we don't know
the answer uh is the short um uh
conclusion but the difficulty of holding
gold
and if somebody pays you in bitcoin not
holding it i think people are gonna have
like a lot of cognitive dissonance on
that one like i i just don't see a world
where if you're willing to buy gold that
is such a uh contrarian investment right
now which maybe that means that it's
actually a good idea nobody knows what
the future holds right past performance
doesn't necessarily uh show what's gonna
happen in the future but the fact that
they're willing to buy gold you gotta
think that they're willing to hold
bitcoin
yes but it's a less volatile volatile
asset obviously and they have shares
only gone down i i
i agree it's obviously appreciated much
more than gold has but just playing
devil's advocate here they have
shareholders right so they have to uh
think about what is in the best interest
of them
and a lot of businesses we've seen that
have come out and gotten a lot of press
for accepting bitcoin have actually
transferred it back into us dollars and
all these things right so one example is
uh the oakland athletics last year they
said hey look you can come and buy a
six-person suite at our stadium for the
next year and we're gonna charge you one
bitcoin this is when it was sixty
thousand dollars the suite uh was going
for about sixty five thousand dollars in
u.s dollars so it wasn't uh it was a
slight discount but essentially they
were just trying to drum up some free
press to fill out the rest of their
suites they ended up i don't even know
if anyone actually ended up uh buying a
sweden bitcoin but they came out later
on and said we were going to convert it
to cash anyways right so
uh it's good from an optionality
perspective but if you're just
converting it right back to us dollars
in the end it doesn't really do much for
the market structure uh but we we'll see
right i think it depends but from a
shareholder perspective uh there's
obviously some people that have concerns
about it i think some people would be
for it and especially when you think
about it in the context of gold uh it's
certainly relatable it's different
but i think that people would be much
more adapt to them holding bitcoin
realizing that they're also paying
storage fees and doing all these things
for for gold yeah so i think that uh
this is very confusing to me the whole
buying gold right here uh is not
something that i would have expected and
so uh
it almost forces me to think through um
and it's a great mental exercise why are
they buying gold and not bitcoin
right is there something else that is at
play here it could simply be the the
people making the decision happen to
like gold hold gold personally they have
a
kind of preconceived um you know
preference for it whatever
it also could be that there's a fear of
bitcoin a misunderstanding of bitcoin
whatever unlikely given that they were
willing to accept it earlier uh but if
you're gonna take 50 million dollars
right now and you said hey pomp you get
50 million where are you gonna buy
bitcoin or gold everyone knows my answer
would be bitcoin right uh but if you
said to a company would you buy bitcoin
or gold palantir is the only business i
know of at the moment that's actually
going and putting gold in their treasury
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it